make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into the
thick of things with Secret Wars part
two okay so this is when things get kind
of cool this is one of reasons why
Secret Wars was so awesome it was one of
these landmark stories that came out for
a bunch of different reasons one of the
big reasons is because it answers
questions like if spider-man fought this
character who would win right and it
would more often than not be spider-man
unless you're talking about a telepath
or reality warper and we'll see why in
this video uh but then there's also
things like Iron Man's armor right for
those guys who were kind of curious at
what point did Tony Stark go from a guy
who just flew around in an Iron Man suit
as a golden Avenger to becoming the guy
who started experimenting with all these
different armor types this answers that
as well so a lot of things came out of
Secret Wars rights one of the reasons
why this story is so important when it
comes to the history of Marvel Comics
and so what this does is it initially
picks up with with with Magneto right
now if you guys recall in the last video
magneto had kind of toyed with the idea
of a lying him selves with you align
yourself with the Avengers but the idea
was that while magneto was essentially
reforming and was on the road to
becoming a good guy which would
ultimately come to fruition an uncanny
x-men number 200 at the moment he was
still seen as a bad guy by the various
heroes who were there and so they
immediately kind of started asking the
question is he a good guy is he a bad
guy and the kind of infighting that
resulted a left magneto with really no
other desire than to just leave
everybody behind right so he ended up
discovering his own personal Citadel
that he was using as a base of
operations now eventually he ended up in
a second conflict with the superheroes
and when that happened he basically
collapsed part of the super heroes
Citadel onto itself and then kidnapped
Janet Van Dyne the wasp but we didn't
really know the reason for that but what
this does is it comes to fruition when
he basically frees Janet Van Dyne and
then of course she kind of pokes around
the place for a little bit and then
ultimately discovers magneto a small
little bit of a skirmish ensues and so
far as she basically shows look you know
I've got my wasp fight I don't really
need to attack you physically but
ultimately magneto bringing her here is
done for the purpose of basically
talking to her and trying to find a way
to communicate and sort of create an
alliance of sorts with the Avengers
right or at least that seems to be the
case and the reason why was because
right off the bat in that first skirmish
magneto basically realized these folks
are gonna listen to reason right they're
held in on the idea that I'm a bad guy
what I'm going to need is one of them to
vouch for me and with Janet Van Dyne
being the leader of the Avengers albeit
Captain America kind of being the field
commander at the moment what better
person to do that then Janet Van Dyne
now I don't know if kidnapping her is
the best way to sort of initiate that
conversation up but it's one of these
things where he does have his own
motivation we'll find out
that is you know as we progress further
but at the very least to kind of seem to
initiate a sort of truce between himself
and the Avengers now following that what
you get is this scenario where the
heroes are kind of piecemealing things
back together right basically taking
these portions of their of their base of
operations kind of bringing it back
together and getting things back in
their place and so on and so forth just
kind of a rebuilding phase right
spider-man is really kind of the main
focal point for this a little bit of the
story and the reason why is he's kind of
making his way through and Peter Parker
you know with all the intellect that he
has is really doing what a lot of other
people don't seem to be doing
spider-man's investigating the area
right he's kind of like looking around
and seeing what's going on like you know
what's up with this whole base of
operations
you know these Citadel's that the
villains have and the ones that we have
and presumably the one that magneto has
seem to kind of cater to our every need
so like let's see how far this goes now
this will become a huge focal point once
you get further into the secret war
story and then you get spider-man black
but until that point Peter Parker just
kind of poking around now ultimately
this leads him to coming across the
x-men and in this moment what do you
basically over here is the x-men talking
about is essentially leaving the
Avengers now again this is one of the
cool things about it and it's one of the
reasons why Jim shooter writing was so
cool is because you get some infighting
here I'm not in the in the sense of a
physical altercation but in the sense of
not everybody's on the same page right
and rightfully so as one of the things
about the x-men they've never really
been on the same page as everybody else
The Avengers protect the world from
various threats and the x-men deal with
the whole mutant threat and inhumanity
and so on and so forth but no one's ever
really been on the on the side of the
x-men right that's one reason why
Avengers vs. x-men was such a big story
is because up until that point you would
see instances where like the x-men of
the Fantastic Four or like the x-men and
The Avengers would team up or something
like that
but it wasn't very often that you heard
of like the right or the Friends of
humanity or apocalypse or some villain
like that popping up and then
potentially destroy the x-men and then
like the Avengers coming to their aid or
the Fantastic Four coming to their aid
you never really saw that all that often
so in a lot of ways the x-men kind of
add on to this philosophy that we're our
own Island right and there which is why
you kind of see the x-men comics right
now with Jonathan Hickman taking on the
form that they are they were always just
kind of out there and isolated in the
world and that's sort of how that's sort
of the approach they're taking now the
issue is you know when they start saying
things like well let's go to magneto and
less Ally with Hamlet form an alliance
this immediately convinces spider-man
that the x-men are essentially working
against the superheroes now this is one
of the most important parts of the story
and the reason why is because we've seen
spider-man face off against various
characters
over the course of time in in Marvel
Comics but the one of the questions that
people ask all the time is if spider-man
fought Wolverine who would win
spider-man fought Colossus who would win
you know who would win in these
different scenarios what we get here is
spider-man facing off against all the
x-men and he beats them all and the
reason why is because of the one thing
spider-man has that nobody else has and
that's his spider sense spider-man's
spider-sense doesn't really say like
Wolverines getting ready to attack you
right now instead it just says like
you're about to be attacked but what it
does is it always keeps him on guard and
it gives him a bit of an edge it's like
Goku from Dragon Ball super with his
ultra plot armor right the idea that it
basically keeps you a step ahead of
everybody else so you never really seem
to have to worry about being defeated
now for spider-man his spider sense does
keep him aware in terms of people
jumping into physical altercations
different things like that so the reason
why this benefits him is because well it
is more of a defensive maneuver right it
basically allows him to get out of
harm's way
you can't hit what you can't touch and
that's basically why spider-man is so
capable here so if you noticed this
between his agility his wedding by his
intellect the whole nine yards he takes
out rogue he takes out Colossus he takes
out Wolverine he basically is able to
dodge storm he takes out Nightcrawler he
takes out the entirety of the x-men like
none of them are really able to even lay
a hand on it he's that capable and it's
one of the reasons if you go talk to Sal
over a common puppets what are the
reasons why he'll be like yeah man
spider-man is like probably one of the
most capable superheroes out there in a
variety of ways now if it comes to
someone like the molecule man Owen Reese
sure he'll turn he'll turn he'll
disperse spider-man's atoms across the
cosmos
so spider-man's not gonna have much of a
chance there and one of the other things
that really comes out of this is how
would spider-man fare against someone
like Charles Xavier and where Xavier
seems to be kind of out of commission
for the moment insofar as spider-man
immediately punches him it's the smart
move to make because Xavier is the only
real credible threat there right because
his power is a mental power and
spider-man can't dodge you know he can't
bob and weave telepathic attacks and
that's really kind of the answer to that
question Howard spider-man fair against
a telepath he wouldn't do very well at
all and the reason why is because once
he gets away from the x-men he gets back
out into the hallway and he comes across
Reed Richards Xavier had used his powers
to wipe spider-man's mind of any
indication but the x-men were working to
go basically ally themselves with
magneto now he is not too happy that he
had to do that but he did it because it
was the only real choice they made and
so grabbing one of the vessels which
only really seems to allow it to be
flown based on thought and then of
course Xavier basically taking the x-man
out into this male
remember this massive storm in turn
leads us over to Magneto end to end -
dr. doom now magneto kind of starts
putting the moves on Janet Van Dyne a
little bit right it's kind of me like
hey look like like you know like you
know girl you know I'm hot but you know
that that's like he's putting the moves
put the moves out right I mean it's kind
of interesting but it's one of these
things where basically dr. doom was
trying to bring on magneto as an ally
now of course magneto immediately turns
him down and when you leave magneto and
Janet Van Dyne and you switch over to to
dr. doom dr. doom kind of laments this
right because the power of Magneto and
the power to control the entire
electromagnetic spectrum is no small
thing and this in other moments like
this are kind of really pointing to this
idea that magneto really is just that
damn powerful what we end up doing is we
basically end up following dr. doom to
where he approaches two characters the
first is Marshall Rosenberg and the
second one is Mary McFerrin now those of
you guys who are reading immortal Hulk
right now and you have titania this is
how she gets her story right this is
Mary McFerrin the blond one who's
human-looking Marshall Rosenberg she
ends up changing her name to volcanic
right and in the way this is played out
it was kind of a tie-in but not really a
took place in she-hulk issue number 10
the way this worked out is that Mary and
and Marcia both lived in Denver right
and around that time that's when you
started to see the rise of Spider Woman
right I think it was Julia carpenter the
original Spider Woman although it may
have been Jessica drew I think was
Jessica drew I don't think she was out
early but I could be wrong there but
regardless when you ended up seeing
Spider Woman kind of making a name for
herself in Denver Denver Colorado this
led to both Marcia and Mary kind of
poking around and seeing what was going
on now while they were largely social
outcasts but what everything took place
at the beginning of Secret Wars one
portion of battle world is composed of
Denver Colorado and so when the Beyonder
took that part of the United States
yanked it out and then brought it in and
in use of deform part of battle world
they came along with it right so during
the she-hulk time that's when you're
introduced to their characters they're
not overly important it wouldn't really
be until after this story they become
important especially volcana and her
relationship with Owen Reese the
molecule man but is one of these things
where titania is like you know where she
was kind of small and scrawny came from
a poor background the abilities Doctor
Doom used to modify her and the give her
powers basically made her a larger woman
made her more of a lung truest woman but
also gave her like super strength
durability different things like that
and so you know following that they're
basically brought in by Doctor Doom to
become allies alongside everybody else
now one of the things that you get right
off the bat is kind of titania looking
to pick a fight with crusher trio the
absorbing man this is where that
relationship starts for those of you
guys who were reading in Mortal Hulk
right now this is where that
relationship
saw for the two of them really kind of
kind of form an on-again off-again
relationship it's really kind of the
definition of an unhealthy relationship
where they're constantly breaking up and
constantly getting back together again
that's more or less where it kind of
kicks off for the molecule man his love
interest really starts to take form in
Marsha right and the reason why is
because we're more she had heard of the
molecule man it's kind of this legendary
guy with this incredible power that he
never really seemed to use to its full
potential she always saw him as more of
like an imposing guy right the kind of
like this really maybe arrogant are very
very haughty guy instead when she meets
him he's a lot more sensitive than she
initially thought he would be and that's
kind of a cool little moment there
because what it does is it lays the
groundwork for the relationship between
the two of them which would actually go
on for more than a little while in
Marvel Comics ah but what is it
happening here is you kind of pick up
with the next morning basically Captain
America wakes up realizing his sunrise
he gets pissed The Incredible Hulk for
not telling him Hale then haida like the
storm basically cleared up because this
is the time when the villains would
attack and they do the villains
basically launched their attack against
all the superheroes and for the most
part with the combined help of titania
and volcana along with Ultron who's
basically been brought back they get the
upper hand quick fast and in a hurry
right I mean they take these guys out
super fast and it's kind of nuts right
it is it's kind of bonkers because
immediately the heroes are kind of
caught unawares and so as a result of
that what the heroes basically fleeing
for their lives for the most part what
you end up getting is one part one of
the more iconic moments of the story and
the reason why I say this is because
you've kind of gotten you know Doctor
Octopus using some some binoculars
basically to be found within the Citadel
and looking for the heroes and
ultimately finds him about five miles
out trying to regroup their forces and
trying to get to a new Citadel or
someplace they can basically hide and
then heal themselves if they can and
then jump back into the fray again but
with that being the case the molecule
man looking to show off two of all
cannon a little bit basically says well
I mean I can stop him right there so
what he is up doing is lifting up an
entire mountain range like a colossal
mountain range and then pushing it over
on top of the heroes and then dropping
it down and it's kind of nuts right it's
kind of bonkers because during this time
one of the reasons why you don't see
Thor here is because Thor had previously
gone to ganda Amora The Enchantress and
then basically said let's leave here and
let's talk about what we would do is go
right they kind of go out and form their
own alliance you've got the Avengers who
are maintaining their alliance you've
got the x-men who go and formed their
own Alliance presumably alongside
Magneto and then if you got Doctor Doom
leading all the villains right so
everybody's splitting up all these
factions are being created so it's one
of these things where everything really
kind of seems to be it seems to be going
to pot - it
now in the midst of all this ultimately
you end up having amaura who basically
you know with the the this giant
mountain range crashing down of course
it sends shockwaves throughout the
entire planet a more grabs Thor they end
up taking off arriving right in front of
the in front of the villains and then
ultimately Doctor Doom basically uses
ultra now of course amaura kind of
realized herself with the villains and
then Ultron basically uses a
disintegration ray as it was seen and
then ultimately just destroys early
seems to destroy Thor right like
completely and totally disintegrate
thort which at the time was kind of
mind-boggling right I mean really for me
the only way to really to know whether
or not this was mind-boggling is to go
back and read the old letters pages but
if you go back and you read the letters
pages for these stories almost crazy
people were blown away they were just
like there's no way Thor was just killed
by Ultron like that's kind of nuts you
know it was a little bonkers to see it
all go down right that's one of the
reasons why letters pages are a really
good resource for seeing how people were
responding to comics back in the day
before you have forums different things
like that but it was kind of a crazy
thing because what is up happening is
the x-men basically arrived to Magneto's
Citadel and it's kind of funny because
as soon as they get there Janet Van Dyne
turns on magneto because what he does is
he tells Charles Xavier basically what
his plan is and what he says here is if
dr. doom basically slayed all the heroes
dr. doom would get his wish right his
wish would be whatever his selfish
desire happens to be which would likely
be dr. doom saying I desire absolute
power over the universe and that would
be it you know with regards to the
Avengers who knows what the Avengers
would do and magneto doesn't really
trust the Avengers because they're
humans even though they're there they
have superpowers
they're not mutants and so it doesn't
really trust them all too much at the
same time what he tells Xavier is if we
had that if we slayed and we killed all
the villains then what we could do is we
could wish for a paradise across the
universe right we're like all mutants
and all humans live in a peaceful
coexistence with each other now it's
kind of an interesting scenario because
on one side you could look at that and
you could say that's a good idea
right because Xavier is plan hasn't
worked Xavier idea of a peaceful
coexistence between humans and Eaton's
just never really seemed to work and
that's what you see playing out in
Jonathan Hickman's x-men right now right
magnet or I'm sorry Xavier is like look
I tried the peaceful route with you guys
you didn't want to play ball so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna form our
own nation and then we're gonna conquer
yours as time goes on we're gonna
basically take it out take over your
infrastructure I I believe in you as
people but I don't believe in my dream
anymore that's that's really kind of the
message that he's been conveying over
the course of of Hickman's x-men run
right so the dream just never really
seemed to work out so that wasn't really
the case if it never really seemed to
work then go for a better option now
typically it does take away the wills of
people but if the wills of people would
have led to like a war between humans
and mutants across the world than just
using some kind of utilitarian stance
it's the best decision to make right
because what you get is better than what
you lose and so as one of these cool
things right is one of these these cool
little debates and philosophical
arguments there goes on with these
various things now what you end up doing
from here is you basically end up
switching over of course we're Janet Van
Dyne goes back into her wasp form and
then in turn the various other x-men neo
try to stop her from going back to the
Avengers and basically saying here's
everything that's gone down wasp manages
to overtake the x-men and an intern
basically bail out to where the Avengers
are located out and so what you end up
doing is you switch over directly to
Incredible Hulk and this again is one of
the most iconic moments of seeker wars
when The Incredible Hulk
is holding a mountaintop cop right now
at this point in time this had never
been seen before we had never seen an
instance of the Incredible Hulk
displaying strength like this and that
was the intention of Jim shooter right
pull out all the stops take these
grandiose displays of each individual
character right so spider-man is a
character who's very very capable let's
show how capable he is by basically
defeating all of the x-men The
Incredible Hulk is super strong let's
show how super strong he is I have him
holding up a mountaintop that's the kind
of thing that Jim shooter was going for
when he was writing secret Wars and
that's why you see things like this and
so what ends up happening here is
because of the fact that the Incredible
Hulk is tiring right it's not something
he could do forever he couldn't really
sit there like four years and hold this
mountaintop you know even the Incredible
Hulk despite all of his strength does
have a limit to a degree this is
compounded by the fact that this is
during the era when you've got basically
the Incredible Hulk strength and Bruce
banners mind right so with that in mind
there are some limits here it's not
infinite it's not really Infinite
insofar as you incredible hooks not
angry right incredible extremes Rises
with his anger at this point he's just
kind of like I really hope we don't die
I was basically yet but but nonetheless
what they end up doing is basically
waking up Reed Richards you know after
he had basically you know passed out or
been knocked out and then in turn he
starts like macgyvering everything right
like he basically ends up taking like
some of Iron Man's armor tapping into it
or the web-shooters of Spider Man the
arrows of Hawkeye is just straight-up
MacGyver and it's just like give me
these small little things but I need
like a rubber band a piece of gum and a
toothpick and by god we'll get out of
here folks
that's kind of what it turns out to be
but what he does is he basically uses
these various things and then manages to
channel these various forms of energy
through Iron Man's armor which going
with a full repulsor blows a hole in a
mountainside now this is why this
matters is because I
through this story going forward where
you saw iron man sort of experimenting
with these small little armor types here
and there this would push everything
into a whole new level and in fact it's
because of this realization of what is
armors capable of what it can truly do
if he puts it to the test and expands on
it that three years after Secret Wars in
1987 Bob Layton wrote Star Wars with
armor wars as is more popularly known
but again it's one of these cool little
things words like Secret Wars spun out a
whole bunch of new stuff from Marvel
Comics which is a pretty big deal that's
why it's such a significant story but
following this the here is basically
knew that it need a new base of
operations right they need a place to go
to in order to remar shal their forces
get their stuff together and get back
into it again and so what you end up
getting is spectrum Monica Rambeau
heading out kind of traveling around
looking for some place where they can
rest and recuperate and then ultimately
discovering a small little village now
his village has like so people in it and
we get largely assume this village is
one of many places that was ripped out
from the universe and basically brought
to form battle world right so it's just
some planet somewhere where they don't
really speak English but they do have
the ability to heal and so they
basically start healing healing Johnny
Storm along with a few other people but
then Ben Grimm suddenly snaps back into
going back into his thing form right so
he's no longer human anymore this will
be explained as we get further into it
but it is kind of a cool little thing
but the big takeaway from all this is
what you end up getting is where
Galactus is kind of standing on this
hillside that does overlook this village
that one is up going on is Reed Richards
is this kind of kind of musing and kind
of looking around and saying okay it's a
little weird that Galactus is is here
but I don't really know why he's here
but I do understand why he you know him
feeling as lonely as he does right the
fact that he's just kind of out here by
himself in the same way that Reed is out
here by himself in a lot of different
ways well then suddenly Galactus moves
and puts his hands in the air and Reed
Richards immediately understands what
this means because what this does mean
is a Galactus is now beginning the
process of putting his machinery
together Galactus is going to start
consuming the battleworld he's gonna
start consuming that entire planet it's
kind of nuts but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explained if we show you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you